[Musique]
bonsoir à tous au cinéma
hiroshima mon amour india sont au
théâtre les viaducs de la seine-et-oise
savané b en librairie un barrage contre
le pacifique moderato cantabile le
ravissement de lol v stein le vice
consul
ce sont là dans une oeuvre abondante est
très diverse quelques-uns des titres qui
ont rendu célèbres marguerite duras et
voilà que cet auteur singulier un peu
mystérieux inclassable certains par
commodité l'on rangé sous la bannière un
peu flou de la modernité
voilà que cet auteur obtient un succès
populaire inouïe avec son dernier livre
la main eh bien c'est la preuve que
marguerite duras c'est encore nous
surprendre et c'est sa présence ici ce
soit en direct apostrophe c'est encore
une bonne surprise
marguerite duras
[Musique]
oh
là
[Musique]
alors je sais bien marri dû à ce que
c'est vrai d'autres succès j'en ai
libéré d'ailleurs avant ce générique
mais quand même celui là cinq mille
exemplaires en quatre semaines c'est
absolument fabuleux
est ce que votre sensibilité qui est
très aiguë très pour le tu avais un peu
pressenti ce succès non non non non tout
au contraire
après le succès de la maladie de la mort
j'avais peur pour ce livre quant à une
paix relative à voter mais j'avais peur
qu'il ne soit pas celui que les gens
attendaient de moi et puis voilà alors
la critique déferlante c'est une vague
quoi quelqu'un dit du mal
ah bon oui il en faut bien un mais des
terres qui me l'a dit quelqu'un a dit on
ne comprend pas qu'un éditeur l'espace
et des fautes de grammaire
on y reviendra d'ailleurs c'est sur le
style alors c'est vrai que les critiques
qu'ils aient boudé d'ailleurs un peu
depuis quelques années puis tout d'un
coup alors il vous retomberez il vous et
c'est il vous couvre de fleurs ça vous
fait plaisir je tapais gêne a aussi
dirigé pendant dix ans
ça a duré dix ans silence autour de moi
et là évidemment c'est un peu dur je ne
peux pas ouvrir journal c'est un peu un
réflexe de pudeur quoi de fuite qui se
produit c'est toujours un temps très
difficiles que que le temps de la
parution d'un livre c'est un peu trop
c'est trop
tout un clan des habitudes de la
critique qui fait que un livre toujours
pris un peu comme une certaine
culpabilité
vous êtes d'accord c'est certain mais
pour les auteurs mais dit
et puis alors j'ai eu une rumeur qui
coure paris certains membres d'haqqani
encore aurélie mais pour que le
devraient tous pas le prix goncourt
lauriad un petit peu les statistiques en
1950 klose a fait paraître ce
chef-d'oeuvre pour moi c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre saper le barrage contre le
pacifique
vous l'avez raté de peu alors la caisse
course est complètement s'est misé à
côté sont pas les mêmes c'est à d'autres
c'était en 50 donc eu aucun ce qu'ils
ont couronné les jeux sauvage de paul
colin le pacifique ils ont laissé tomber
et d'avoir du regret et voulez pas vous
ne trouverez pas le donner à un barrage
parce que j'étais de gauche
j'étais communiste à ce moment là enfin
j'étais membre du pc qui fait que les
barrages c'est une expérience
épouvantable pour la famille pour ma
mère et que j'en était puni par ailleurs
quand j'en ai parlé quand j'en ai écrit
en revenons à la main oui la mort nous
sommes nous sommes à saillon entre les
deux guerres dans les années 20 vous
avez quinze ans et demi et vous êtes sur
un bac qui traversent le fleuve c'est à
dire le mékong
il faisait drôlement hâtif et voulaient
pas que cet actif et comment un grand
dénuement
j'ai un chapeau d'homme un feutre oui un
feutre rose couleur bois de rose ont
large ruban noir mais et au pied j'ai eu
ce chapeau là vraiment je les ai eus au
pied gdd la meilleure des sujets de vos
dossiers
c'est vraiment sur le bac évidemment
vous devez faire doit vous remarqué
aujourd'hui on vous remarquerez à peine
parce qu'une mode qui se porte court à
manger jeune fille
oui mais c'est vrai aujourd'hui vous
remarquerez pas mais à cette époque on
vous remarquerez d'ailleurs quelqu'un
vous a remarqué qui est dans une grande
limousine noire vous regards se croisent
et on peut dire est ce qu'on peut dire
que cet échange de regard a changé votre
vie oui le livre s'appelait avant la
photographie absolue il m'a été commandé
ce livre attention et cette photographie
absolue n'avait pas été prise si vous
voulez c'était celle-là
cet instant-là du bac on n'avait rien vu
qu'un homme note au noir est une jeune
fille et des cars pour indigènes mais
c'est de l'acte du parti le fleuve une
fois traversée qu'il ya donc il y at-il
dans la voiture noire alors vous en
donner cet humoriste léon bollée oui
mais je n'envoie plus de ces autos
darwin ont amusé je pense que si on
s'était assis là devant l'autre on
aurait été est à cette distance là avec
cette auto à cette auto jeudi
gigantesque alors qu'ils vous regardent
est un chinois très riche mais vous ne
savez pas qui dirige à ce moment là si
je le sais à l'automobile et puis au
chauffeur je sais les choses comme ça il
a 12 ans puisque vous j'ai 15 ans il a
27 ans oui ça et vous savez on a
l'impression que vous savez qui va
devenir votre ami votre premier roman
tout de suite de dire que j'ai su après
qu'il ne m'avait pas dit plus sur le bac
mais sur le moment je n'avais pas d'avis
sauf que j'étais assez étonné par
touches étape qui raillent de
milliardaires je teins pétonnet un peu
pataud et attirer aussi bien sûr vous
dit
j'avais à 15 ans le visage de la
jouissance et je ne connaissais pas la
jouissance
ce visage se voyait très fort même ma
mère devait le voir mes frères le voyais
tout a commencé de cette façon pour moi
par son visage voyant exténué ses yeux
cernés en avance sur le temps les faits
il est fait a été remplacé par
expérimente et on a l'impression
c'est cette impression que j'aime bien
en lisant votre livre que vous savez dès
le premier regard des six premiers à
vous échangez avec ce jeune chinois
qu'il va vous donner le plaisir vous
allez connaître avec lui le plaisir et
la jouissance
si vous voulez dans le livre je veux
dire
donné je le dis même sur le bac déjà me
plaît mais je ne peux pas dire si
précisément que ça que vous lui dites là
que je savais ça donc mesdames été
embarqué avec lui
embarqué dans l'histoire de tout le
monde je devais y passer quoi ils
descendent du plaisir pas ça me
remplissait de une certaine joie d'une
certaine tristesse si c'était quand même
le petit monde ma mère mais d'user d'une
certaine joie aussi d'être comme les
autres
mais qu'est ce qui vous attire lui
l'argent la douceur puis se fait bizarre
c'est que je suis créole vous savez je
suis né là bas et c'était il était comme
un petit peu du même lieu que moi un peu
contre ma mère si vous voulez chasser a
dû se passer comme ça et très vite vous
allez dans sa garçonnière
oui très vite il ya vous aime il est fou
d'amour pour vous c'est normal aussi une
petite comme ça tout petit et vous vous
ne l'aimez pas c'est pas je peux pas
dire ça alors c'est quoi quels sont les
caisses qui entre vous en dehors du
plaisir
j'avais quand les choses ne sont pas
dites ne pas été dit là ne m'a pas elles
ont été pensées clairement après pendant
le retour sur le paquebot qui me
ramenait en france sur nietzsche à
quantième un jeune homme s'est tué il
s'est jeté à l'eau et
j'étais en pleine nuit le bateau est
arrêté mais trop tard le corps a été
perdu et 7 c'est cette séparation du
corps du jeune homme l'a rendu à cette
évidence que je l'avais aimé c'est la
séparation d'avec le corps du jeune
homme à qui ma rendu à cette évidence la
gelée sans doute aimé en montant dans sa
voiture et on a là dans sa garçonnière
vous saviez que vous créez vous avez
créé à ce moment-là double scandale
vous avez un candidat parce qu'on a le
vôtre est il aussi le sien quand à sa
famille williams j'ai pas pensé à ça
j'ai pas pensé à ça non je dis quand
même fait pas penser au déshonneur
puisque je l'appelle de ce grand mot
c'est un mot de ma mère non j'ai pas
pensé à ça je pensais qu'il fallait y
aller je vivais avec deux versions qui
qui était très en avance sur moi de ce
point de vue je pense que j'ai voulu
rejoindre mes frères oui mais vous
commettez quand même une transgression
extraordinaire parce que là vous allez
vous avez 15 ans et demi nous est mineur
et vous devenez la maîtresse de
un chinois alors vraiment c'est une
double provocation et cette provocation
et très mal reçue par votre famille vous
dites maîtresse ballaman une maîtresse
de l'autre côté
oui avant tout c'était ça j'étais la
jouissance
c'était très très très fort c'était pour
toute la vie oui vous raconter c'est
l'incroyable le il offre des déjeuners
ou des dîners de famille c'était comme
série b et personne ne lui dit rien
alors surtout au niveau des mers niveau
frère il ignore complètement ça alors
pas un monde et ces messieurs se devait
d'aider repas effrayant où il mangeait
s'occuper de rien d'autre
il vous mangez énormément tous tu t on
n'avait jamais l'occasion d'occasions de
manger des choses pareilles de ce prix
là moi je commençais à avoir l'habitude
puisque je sortais tout le temps avec
lui mais pour mes frères c'est une
véritable orgie et jacques où il était
on était sans gène nommé t on était
d'une très grande brutalité
la mère elle l'a pas élever ses enfants
on était devant comme derrière qu'on
était naturel ja je la corde à mes
frères et moi on était comme des animaux
noble terrible vraiment je peux dire que
depuis ces mots sauvages qui revient le
plus donc ils n'avaient pas se gêner
devant lui il ne faisait pas mais ça
allait plus loin saleh qu'il était jaune
aussi que kylie des chinois et que nous
étions des blancs
et où vous êtes dans un pensionnat
d'ailleurs vous y allez quand vous
voulez la discipline est tout de même ça
c'est au pensionnat et vous êtes mis en
quarantaine parce qu'un peu sage chinois
il vient avec son pensionnat s'étaient
l'aider maîtrise et des gens pauvres
il ne s'occupait pas des quarantaines
oui non c'est pas parce qu'ils étaient
non cette police et oui ce n'est au
lycée on ne parlait pas là quelle force
de caractère vous aviez pour supporter
tout ça se visite du leader est ce que
j'ai vécu ma main l'horaire de l'enfance
votre meilleure balle 11 ans alors
c'était rien que les banquiers de saison
des allergies il faut que nous parler à
celle là est ce qu elle couche avec des
chinois rebond votre mea parlons-en
oui alors on trouve sont entrés dans un
barrage contre le pacifique
c'est elle qui domine d'ailleurs tout le
livre alors elle était institutrice elle
était insuffisant en france et puis elle
s'est engagée dans l'armée coloniale on
peut dire dans l'instruction publique
elle était institutrice oui tout ça
vient c'est otis d'école indigènes qui
fit que nous avons vécu dans la brousse
presque tout le temps toute l'enfance et
pourquoi quitter l'enseignement pour
acheter une concession elle n'a pas
quitté l'a pas quittée elle a continué à
en installer oui parce que c'était très
difficile quand même élevé trois enfants
c'était très peu d'argent ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle gagnait et elle a voulu
devenir riche pour nous à ce moment là
l'administration française loti c'est la
partie la partie sud du cambodge entre
le cham la chaîne de l'éléphant et les
il y avait ce qu'on appelle les comment
s'appelle ce assez ces grandes
plantations de la text caoutchouc eh
bien non dans l'économie coloniale des
concessions s'appelle les concessions
mais ces plantations des rouge et blanc
tailleur rouge
ce mot viendra elle a acheté une terre
pour pour faire du riz et elle a
effectivement oui la porter au cadastre
même pas de compte en banque est ce
qu'on voit là des choses comme ça elle
descend en tout cas elle n'avait jamais
elle a porté 20 ans d'économies à ces
gens qui ont qui l'ont vu venir
elle venait de la brousse c'est l'été
sans mari elle avait trois enfants à
charge et elle était institutrice des
colonies gêne c'est à dire au dernier
rang de la société blanche
alors ils y ont donné très facilement
enfin avec le sourire une concession
complètement pourri que la mère
envahissait voilà oui et c'est là c'est
tout l'épisode de barrage dans le
pacifique et parce qu'elle se révèle
qu'elle veut pas que la halle la mer
c'est la mer de chine envahissent
implantation il faut dresser des
barrages et l'ars qui m'ont pas tenir
parce qu'ils sont bouffés par d
l'estivage expliquera la force de la
marée mais alors il a été bernée etc
mais vous dites me manquait était folle
vous dites l'été de naissance dans le
sang oui oui je crois je ne peux pas
vous dire en quoi elles étaient très
précisément elle l'était peut-être parce
qu'elle avait acheté cette terre là
cette naïveté pouvez vous pouvez aussi
la folie
elle était en tout cas elle était folle
oui quand elle était dans la loire la
fin elle était folle et puis vous
raconter qu'elle a je suis plus je crois
que la marge dans le pacifique que elle
a joué pendant dix ans du piano dans un
cinéma
oui c'est pas vrai ça c'est par une
annonce est pas vrai alors près du piano
mais oui abondance à s'inventer parce
que moi j'ai une autre femme
moi j'ai fabuler je pense que je me suis
dit alors dont il a joué pendant dix ans
du 15 ans il a donc l a jamais vu le
film puisque ont joué pendant les films
passés et je me suis dit tiens marie
duras donc est venu au cinéma peut-être
pour que sa mère vois ses films ben
ouais voilà ce que je me suis dit mais
évidemment c'est complètement fou alors
ce portrait qu'on trouve dans un barrage
contre le pacifique est ce qui
s'applique à votre mère on ne pouvait
plus lui en vouloir il avait été mais
démesurément la vie et c'était son
espérance infatigable incurable qui en
avait fait ce qu'elle était devenue une
désespérée de l'espoir même cet espoir
là l'accusé détruites nidifient à ce
point que son sommeil qui leur posaient
même la mort semble et il ne pouvait
plus le dépasser votre carrière
et quand elle est l'anglais les
administrateurs qu'ils ont berné il ya
cinq pages dûment super vraiment les
traîne dans la boue en dix ans jusqu'à
la fin je vous poursuivre est une
malédiction
savait elle n'avait pas d'interlocuteur
donc c'est à nous qu'elle disait tout ça
c'est mes berceuse sert l'histoire de la
concession
c'est avec ça qu'on a grandi
la terre incroyable du barrage on allait
tout le temps qu'elle fournit resté
plusieurs mois d'affilée aux vacances
mais c'était à nous qu'elle parlait
c'était le cinéma ma mère je ne t'ai pas
musicienne c'était le cinéma et votre
frère aîné alors là un voyou de famille
un fouilleur d'armoires un assassin sans
armes
ça existe c'était un voyou oui mais
quand même vous m'accordez que j'ai
innocenté tout le monde
ah oui vous aimez je pense que c'est ça
la main tout le monde est innocenté aux
frères aussi peut-être que c'est la clé
qu'il est vraiment que c'est fini c'est
fini je veux dire leur sentiment
terrible que j'avais contre lui c'est
fini depuis peut-être ça parce que les
moments depuis le livre depuis que j'ai
racontée en toute liberté
ce qu'il était capable de faire mais et
puis il ya un petit frère qui va mourir
en 42 oui mais oui c'est diviser pour
mallett ça oui mais quelle relation dans
cette famille parce que ceux des
relations d'amour et de haine c'est tout
mélanger comme dans toutes les familles
non parce que les familles sont
peut-être moins singulière que la vôtre
côté moi quand je vois des enfants tout
à fait heureux détendu police charmant
tu me dire quelque chose qui était
contourné un certain naturel peut-être
un jeu jeu de le voir le jeu de la loi
de la loi de l'espèce terme avec les
parents disent toujours plus tard tu
verras plus tard tu feras ça pour quoi
ça veut dire que tu as même vin je la
mange je le dis dans un dressage vous
comme ça que j'ai vécu je mangeais ce
paradis de cette mère qui était tout à
la fois valeur
[Musique]
l'injustice l'horaire et si vous avez vu
une autre mère c'est à dire par exemple
une une française riche que mais ce que
vous auriez écrit voulez mon avis oui
bien sûr je croirais toute façon vous
auriez cru oui il était plus fort que ma
mère elle même
c'est la seule chose qui soit qu'il
était plus forte qu'elle
peut-être le petit frère était il était
plus fort mais parce que quand même je
considère que le petit frère est mort de
meurtre il était tué par le frère aîné
je ne peux pas me défaire de sa voulez
pardonner quand même j'ai pardonné mais
je ne peux pas me défaire de cette de
cette causalité cible et c'est lui qui
l'a tué une scène qui m'a rappelé un
libre de bercot est fille unique de ma
mère vous aussi vous avez eu honte de
votre mère oui vous dire qu'il y avait
de quoi elle était ne porte comment
habillé n'importe comment
je n'ai jamais vu des souliers décembre
était toujours de suivi skaté débat de
cotonou
mais tous les enfants de leur mère quand
elle est mal habillé quand elle et quand
tu as les cheveux tirés et quand et
surtout quand on sort d'un lycée où les
mères venait quelques fois et où elle
était resplendissante
elle arrive dans sa vie 12
et puis bien côté il ya une super
limousine qui vous attend avec un
chauffeur mais je comprends que des
urnes
vous avez honte aujourd'hui devant le
monde non gt rien j'étais un peu rond
tout l'anglais puis apprécié
et à ce qu'elle avait honte de votre
liaison avec le chinois elle la
connaissait pas comme la connaissez pas
haltiner avec vous oui mais elle ne
savait pas ce qui se passait je compare
on avait une chose pire pour elle que
les barrages c'était cette appartenance
à la race blanche était raciste
lotion racistes comme tous les coloniaux
ça a été pire encore si elle avait
appris que sa fille couchée avec la
chine loin puisque les barrages c'est
pas peu dire ce que je vous dis là c'est
le tpir il vous ne le savez pas elle n'a
jamais su mon frère aîné je n'ai jamais
osé lui dire il m'a supplié supplier six
ans après c'est un prêt de lui dire une
fois non
votre mère aussi oui le petit frère ne
demandez rien n'est jamais rien demandé
et cette liaison avec le chinois durer
combien de temps et comment at-elle fini
1 duré un an et demi je suis parti en
france
par le bateau c'est une part les pattes
beauté une admirable scène telle que
vous la raconter une chose qui est un
peu curieux c'est que on retrouve votre
mère en france dans un château avec des
meules sa communauté dans une misère
extraordinaire on se dit mais comment
comment at elle pu acquérir un château
en france elle avait fondé une école
la nouvelle école française
vous l'avez des petits français du petit
métis des petits des petits jeunes amis
très riches
il avait gagné de l'argent
avec cet argent il avait acheté deux
propriétés une âme aux frères et une
aile
tout est toutes été vendues pour deux
ans en faveur du frère et le frère le
voyou est mort si vous appelez le voyez
où je ne permettrai pas autrement
oui j'appelle mais c'est un voyou wall e
s que il est mort quand il est mort
comme on n'est pas très longtemps il ya
quelques années voilà trouvé mort dans
sa chambre et votre mère et ma tante un
jeu typiquement jeudi avoir une
vingtaine d'années que les mains mais
son fils younes était sa passion votre
mère de son enfant
j'étais son enfant
je ne sais pas comment ça je n'ai eu
qu'un enfant je ne sais pas comment des
injustices de cet ordre peuvent
s'installer parce que en principe une
mère et c'est ça le miracle elle aime
également de façon préférentielle tous
ses enfants mais ils sont enterrés
ensemble
le maire lire aujourd'hui quand ils sont
ensemble comme les amants chinois alors
revenons en à ce style de la manche je
vais je vais lire un passage pas ça me
donne je trouve superbe parce que il
veut bien vous donner les
téléspectateurs c'est le style là c'est
une scène d'amour
il s'agit donc de l'amant ils vous
regardent ils la regardent les yeux
fermés de la regarde encore ils
respirent son visage ils respirent
l'enfant les yeux fermés il respire sa
respiration c'est air chaud qui ressort
d'elle il discerne de moins en moins
clairement les limites de ce corps celui
ci n'est pas comme les autres il n'est
pas fini dans la chambre il grandit
encore il est encore sans forme arrêter
à tout instant en train de se faire il
n'est pas seulement là où il le voit il
est ailleurs aussi il s'étend au delà de
la vue vers le jeu de la mort il est
souple il part tout entier dans la
jouissance comme s'ils étaient grands en
âge il est sans malice d'une
intelligence effrayante
alors ce style qui
ou est-ce qu'il est très travaillé ou
est ce qu'au contraire il coule comme ça
de sources ça j'ai dû le faire comme ça
la première fois comme ça à faire je
sais pas tout du foie c'est la première
fois tu as souvent avec l'iss et je
corrige pas quand je parle de la moi
c'est les autres choses que je travaille
parce qu'il continue à vous inspirer
oui oui les une sorte de mise en abyme
et voulait il a éclipsé les autres
amours dans ma vie de ma vie sans doute
parce qu'il a été sans énoncer sans
déclaration il ya quelque chose là
d'inépuisables effectivement dans
l'émotion j'ai même visible que je dois
dire même physique on peut se rappeler
aujourd'hui un plaisir inouï
et à partir de ce livre j'ai compris
combien j'avais désirer mais ferait
surtout le petit il ya quelque chose en
lui si vous voulez qui est du petit
frère du fait de la race de cette race
jaune qui était inférieure pour nous la
nôtre dû de ce fait là pour lui et du
fait pour mon petit frère qu'il était en
retard retard sur la vie enfin on dirait
maintenant oui c'est ça retarde et ils
se rejoignent pour moi ça peut être
compliqué
je reviens au style alors tous les
critiques se disent mais fichtre comment
comment s'est fait ce style d'où
viennent vient sa séduction d'où vient
son magnétisme
alors là vous savez je crois que c'est
parce que je ne m'en occupe pas du style
je n'occupe pas là j'ai dit les choses
comme elles nous arrivent sur moi je
fais le geste tous savent comme attac si
vous voulez quand même aveugle je pose
des mots beaucoup de fois des mots
d'abord vous ayez c'est comme si
l'étendue de la phrase était ponctuée
par la place des mots et que par la
suite
la france s'attache au mollet prend et
et s'accorde à eux comme elle le peut
mais que moi je m'en occupe infiniment
moins que des mots c'est ce qui est
curieux c'est que vous faites des
répétitions volontaire vous placez vous
placer des mots d'une manière bizarre
qui doit effectivement heurter des
professeurs un peu plus risée ça c'est
ça c'est l'évidence et avec cette chose
cette chose
j'avais commencé avec les régimes à être
incorrectes rêver alors avec ce style un
peu bizarre un peu singulier et c'est là
le miracle c'est que vous obtenez
vous arrivez à dire les choses d'une
manière juste précise et rapide
c'est ça qui est étonnant mais ça j'en
étais pas sûr avant quand le lisier je
me disais on ne pourra pas tenir avec ça
on aura envie des phrases enfin d'un
déroulement plus classique de la france
ben non ça marche comme ça ça fonctionne
comme ça je disais que vous savez que la
lettre et que tu courante que je
cherchais depuis si longtemps de
l'atteinte
maintenant j'en suis sûr et que par
écouter eau courante je dirais et que
dure presque discrète qui courent les
plus pressés d'attraper les choses que
de les dire voyez vous mais je parle de
la crête des mots c'est une écriture qui
courait choix sur la crête pour aller
vite pour ne pas perdre parce que quand
on écrit c'est le drame on oublie tout
de suite et c'est affreux quelquefois au
fond vous l'avez écrit solide avec un
sentiment d'urgence
j'étais moins dedans c'était l'histoire
qui était d'urgente unis le style aussi
une histoire a appelé lui revient d'une
façon urgente d'être écrite comme ça que
je les ressentis comment écrivez-vous
expliquez-moi comment ça se passe je
fais derrière d'abord je fais des les
feuilles ou quelquefois ça reste non
mais avant avant du matin que ce qui s'y
passe matin le premier deal soit
n'importe quand n'importe quand
quelquefois quelquefois la halle à la
fin j'ai complètement nu par le le livre
acheté j'avais le sentiment que le bruit
revenait lorsque je je sais c'est
d'écrire mais j'arrive à travailler dix
heures par jour je vous dans un
entretien que vous pouvez pas écrire ce
n'est pas fait votre mise
c'est assez vrai mais maintenant je peux
plus le faire depuis que j'ai subies
cette cure alors on le sait gentiment
mais c'est vrai qu'une chambre la
qualité fait ça dérange le oui il faut
que ça en ordre derrière soi comme la
vaisselle dans la cuisine
ah bon non plus pour qu'elle soit rangé
la véore oui le l'ordre c'est en dehors
dans alors donc vous quoi vous n'avez
pas la machine vous écrivez j'étais
jeune je tapais la machine maintenant
n'en jetez plus la magie mais ce livre à
la main ou les écrits en combien de
temps
quand moi dans les mauvais dont nous
parlons dans un instant vous avez dit à
yann andréa écrire on croit que c'est
facile c'est le contraire vous le savez
c'est l'enfer les ingérer pas un peu
mais pas là avant c'était l'enfer
mais pas là car on dirait ma chronique
sur le bonheur on peut aussi écrire sans
souffrir sans trop souffrir parce que
l'âge avancé dans l'inconnu j'aime les
missions difficiles fait une chose
impossible
mais quand même c'était plus fort que
moi mais oui c'est à dire des clients
dans un commentaire à propos de votre
feeling dias on vous avait dit ceci un
écrivain c'est intenable
ça fait du mal faut m'expliquer ça ça se
fait du mal où ça fait du bien ça fait
du mal c'est intenable d'être un
écrivain wii n'est pas là quoi
pas de vie la vie est ailleurs
c'est un drôle de truc de lecture encore
se double de sang se double d'une d'une
autre vision du réel pourquoi tout le
temps ce cheminement de l'écrit à côté
de la vie duquel on ne peut absolument
pas à s'extraire lui plaît beaucoup
parlé de ça et puis je sais pas ce que c
est que je sais pas c'est toujours pas
non mais j'ai beaucoup parlé croyant
savoir
puis en mars mais alors j'ai donné des
renseignements je donnais des
renseignements sur l'écrit mais sa voix
un peu de quoi ça procède
essentiellement je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas je dis pas des gens très très
célèbres comme moi n'ont pas écrit les
en sarthe le pas écrit comme nom pour
moi il n'a pas écrit n'a pas su ce que
c'était écrire mais toujours il a eu
l'air si vous voulez il ait toujours des
soucis
addex des soucis en 2d le seconde main
il n'a jamais affronté l'écriture pur
c'est un moraliste sarthe pour cela que
toujours puisé dans la dans la société
dans une espèce de weeds d'environnement
de lui en environnement politique
littéraire je n'ai pas que quelqu'un de
qui je dirais il écrit je ne penserai
même pas j'ai lu une chose qui
m'intéressait ludon situation parler de
la littérature américaine s'en sert à
rien les mots
ainsi j'ai lu ça oui je dirais que man
show écrit bataille écrit oui quand
est-ce que vous avez su que vous
deviendriez un écrivain mais vous savez
c'est pas un jugement de valeur que je
manque de là il ya des gens qui est quoi
écrire
et puis des gens qui écrivent ces rares
je travaille quand avez vous su que vous
seriez avec rival avec votre mère vous
pousser à l'agrégation de mathématiques
et quand elle vous lui avait dit oh non
je dois écrire des romans terral
on était très bien ma mère elle s'en
foutait complètement une jetta qu'à
faire du commerce c'est mieux qu'avant
le disait elle pensait jeudi histoire de
ridicule quand est ce que je vais
demander quand est-ce vous aviez eu la
sensation très profonde que vous
écririez que vous seriez un écrivain
nationaux qui me l'a dit ça mais que
nous étions mais j'ai fait un premier
livre qui a été refusé par tout le monde
et je parle pas de ça vous étiez norme
est atteint dans le dos chez nous dit
maintenant je vais écrire oui quand j'ai
décidé de vous avez 15 ans 14 ans je
sais plus en 12 ans c'est ça je veux
savoir je les livre qui donne envie
d'écrire kelio les deux classements
mais votre frère aîné à l'emploi dit
donc c'est terrible de classe vous dites
c'était un fouilleur d'armoires j'adore
cette expression mais les écrivains vous
vous êtes aussi une fougueuse d'un - on
n'était pas fouiller les armoires les
limites et tout ce qui est tout où les
commodes l'ailé les tiroirs n'ai pas
cessé de fouiller vous convenez qu'une
autre qu'au fond et qu'il est non jours
c'était avec une salle et a fouillé tout
et tout est imaginaire ccpd fiction mes
trucs mes livres si tout parent c'est la
première fois oui oui mais oui mais tous
se retrouvent se dit 70 dans tous vos
livres
c'est ça qui m'a intrigué figurez vous
pourquoi j'étais chercher là j'avais 8
ans lorsque j'ai connu administrés terre
pourquoi j'ai été chercher cette femme
vous faire une garçon curieux c'est ce
que c'est ça qui a fait que je me suis
dit je vais écrire sur cette période
rien de me disais que ça mais ça tout ça
c'est de la fiction
j'ai connu personnes notamment des
râteaux même l'été 80 une fiction mais
ce qui est déjà bas vous connaissez
personne parce que les gens se
retrouvent dans lyon est ce qui est des
gens qui disent ah oui c'est moi un
agitateur langage dans d'autres
vice-consul levis qu'en chine beaucoup
d'âmes beaucoup d'eau
oui je voulais vous dire quelque chose
je reviens à la main je reparle
je me plagie là dedans sur la mendiante
c'est déjà écrit tout ça oui c'est
presque comme des personnages on les
retrouve dans tous nos lives la
mendiante vice-consul à tous ceux qui
sont familiers de votre savent très bien
qu'on est con on les retrouve sous
d'autres formes
mais alors votre livre l'amant commence
par deux pages sur votre visage
alors c'est intéressant parce que les
téléspectateurs voient votre visage
alors vous dites qu'à 18 ans bien 18 ans
vous dites que votre visage a changé
subitement il y avait votre visage du
moment vous avez rencontré le chinois
votre amant puis à 18 ans vous dites
banos il a changé mon visage il est
devenu ce qu'il est je n'ai pas 18 ans
mais là oui j'ai changé énormément entre
16 et 18 ans mais regardez ces photos
que j'ai on les montre oui mais vous
voyez le visage
oui j'ai cerné germé alors vous dites
que donc c'est ce visage maintenant vous
le traitez de dévaster et vous êtes dur
avec vous-même puisse vous dit j'ai un
visage lacéré de riedseltz et profonde à
la peau cassé il ne s'est pas à fait
c'est comme certains visages très fin il
a gardé les mêmes contours mais sa
matière est détruite
j'ai un visage détruit j'aime bien la
phrase aux examens visage détruit
oui non parce qu'il est enfin là j'ai la
peau du visage détruit très vive très
bien
je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai écrit
là-dessus parce que vous sortiez de
votre cure de désintoxication
probablement et que tout de suite après
vous parlez de l'alcool j'ai l'équipe a
abordé dans lol
la télévision c'est le frère de prévert
et qui vous a dit je vais faire
maintenant je vais lire la phrase je
vous connais depuis toujours
tout le monde dit que vous étiez belle
lorsque vous étiez jeune je suis venu
pour vous dire que pour moi je vous
trouve plus belle maintenant que lorsque
vous étiez jeune j'aimais - votre visage
de jeune femme que celui que vous avez
maintenant dévasté il ya dix ans qu'est
ce que votre également dévasté acheter
contente fin je trouvais qu'il était sûr
tout en ciel à lui disant ça il est venu
en oblique il est arrivé droit sur moi
pour me dire ça et je trouvais ça
complètement adorable bon ce visage
c'est vous même qui le dit a été ravagé
par l'alcool bon et 20 seulement pas
seulement par la vie là rien
actuellement aussi par l'écriture est
venue après la vie avec la mort ouais
qu'on parle de minutes de l'écriture
bien sûr elle me dit que c'est
l'écriture l'écriture oui bien sûr
d'écriture d'un des rides aux écrivains
[Musique]
et aux lecteurs aussi bon l'année
dernière
yann votre ami et yann andréa publié un
livre intitulé tout simplement et menez
qui est un livre terrible panne belgique
magnifique mêmes effets auxquels il
raconte votre au début c'est votre
suicide à l'alcool et ensuite votre cure
de désintoxication qu absolument
terrifiante mais alors une question
pourquoi vous le mari de duras ou vous
suicide y est à l'alcool vin rouge
pourquoi c'est parce que j'ai une
alcoolique
mais pourquoi tous ces choristes mais
pourquoi à ce que j'ai j'ai connu des
hommes qui me faisait boire
j'ai commencé comme ça avec qui je
sortais tout les choix mondiale que lui
comme ça oui mais en ce moment je suis
une alcoolique qui ne boit pas si vous
voulez ne doit pas tout à l'heure je
vais bien et un verre de scotch
je n'ai pas fait on peut plus boire une
goutte d'alcool et nos quêtes quand il
disait le docteur même pas un bonbon que
vous avez écrit d'ailleurs un livre
s'appelle détruire dit elle je me suis
dit est ce que un certain moment vous
n'avez pas ou vous la volonté je ne sais
pas pour des raisons peut-être même
littéraire parce que ça marchait moins
bien lui parce que l'écriture
fonctionnait moins bien de vous détruire
vous savez en bois parce qu'elle peut
dieu n'existe pas il est remplacé par
l'alcool il ya plus de problème je
voulais c'est certainement quelque chose
de
je sais ce que c'est mais je peux pas en
parler des bienfaits que j'ai commencé à
boire tout seul chez moi mais à partir
du moment où seul j'avoue j'ai fait 3
alors là il cette cure de
désintoxication c'est effrayant ce que
vous avez endurés c'est effrayant et
ramos avait cette formule que je trouve
sublime ce que je viens de subir
c'est épouvantable c'est comme si on
vous mettait de la dynamite dans le
corps et que ça n'explose jamais c'est
ce que vous dites à vianne andré mais
c'est aussi très drôle
non non non non moi je dis que je suis
complètement vague que j'ai dit que les
tropiques du cancer passe par la 17ème
arrondissement j'ai l'obligation d'un
délit vous délire éthylique
effectivement il ya des choses drôles
mais quand vous au bord du délirium
tremens et que vous voyez les bestioles
partant on peut pas dire tant que sales
trader on enchaîne c'est pas drôle ça
quand même
est ce que j'ai réussi quelque chose
qu'à capter quelque chose qui fait que
j'ai écrit ce livre
après je me suis reconnue comme ma mère
me décrivez c'est l'aele râlera toujours
elle sera jamais contente
puis elle n'en pense pas moins et ses
amis quand je jure dans les couloirs
pour le café le matin même si je
reconnais comme ça quand même
et j'en étais j'étais heureuse d'avoir
conservé cette nature voyez que je la
nature que j'avais pas parce qu'un thd
est ce que tu aimais pas ma nature
ça c'est très très fort olive l'amant
est le signe tangible de votre retour à
la vie oui je peux pas dire que j'ai à
venir vie non c'est pas possible après
quand on a subi une cure comme ça que je
trouve une résurrection
mêlez vous êtes fichés dans vous à une
résurrection parce que vous voyez devant
vous non mais j'ai lu ça mais j'ai dit
mais c'est incroyable que la durée
vous avez failli mourir d'ailleurs le
médecin diablement encore alors attendu
trois jours de plus elle était morte
mais ce qu'il veut pas dire que quand on
sort ça soit une résurrection ya quelque
chose de de démolir quand même je peux
plus boire oui mais vous êtes je te
revoir peut plus boire mais c'est les
larmes de tant bonne santé et vous
appuyez je ne vois pas et j'ai pu
vraiment je me suis même demandé si vous
n'aviez pas écrit la main cette
jubilation dans la mangeoire d asi
jubilation maintenant je me sentais que
j'avais créé avant non pas du tout non
je me suis demandé si ça n'était pas dû
à ce c'est presque ce retour à ce poste
il vous sentez quelle jubilation dans
votre écriture dans le dos le mans jeune
aire un point d'honneur derrière des
cris je me suis demandé si c'est pas
parce que justement vous aviez échapper
à tout ça vous reveniez d'enfer vous
revenez de l'enfant a coûté mais c'est
effrayant ce livre mais vous ne savez
pas quand vous êtes comme ça vous êtes
très bien quand on boit moi j'étais
mouvante j'étais jeune j'avais quinze 15
50 par jour
je ne savais pas je rigolais quand je
vous révèle les syncopes fayon bon
quelques grands thèmes canton dans votre
votre votre peuple
les voitures alors les voitures c'est
étonnant parce que dans là il ya donc là
il ya là maurice léon bollée de la main
mais dans le dans le barrage pacifique
ya toujours le lot si le chinois qui
attend avec une voiture
le torpédo de la joie cylindres dans la
marge dans le pacifique
et puis alors il ya la lancia citroën et
puis elle allie lancia noir du alors du
vice-consul d'ailleurs vous rappelle de
l'ambassade de france à défendre rappelé
le début de ligne à india song c'est la
lancia noir fils sur la route de
chandernagor c'est ça qu'est ce que
toutes ces voitures grande voiture
limousine une obsession ça représente
quoi
les autos noir qui s'appelle louis jeudi
les lotos funèbre de mon enfance
whissell ça représente des signes
extérieurs de richesse comme ça au
premier degré mais cela représentait
l'impossible pour nous pour la famille
ma mère mes frères
ça représente le voyage on voulait dans
des conditions incroyables et plus du
tout capote y avait plus de pneus ont
été les feuilles de bananiers dans les
polders
il y avait plus tard vous avez dû tout
ça alors là tout mobile c'était le luxe
c'était vraiment la richesse ça c'était
la richesse et puis les tennis qui
frappait aussi de voir ça les
techniciens de tennis de votre c'était
la richesse c'était aussi la région il y
avait des tennis que dans le parc de
l'administration générale des tennis et
des réceptions
mais je n'allais mis au tennis ni aux
réceptions j'avais 8 ans c'était
inaccessible
c'était pourtant c'est là tout le temps
partout il ya des tennis et puis les
cris alors là qu'est ce qu'on peut créer
dans votre les cris du vice consul qui
sont restés célèbres mais les cris
d'amour bon il écrit de la mendiante
qu'on retrouve dans
dans toutes les crises votre mère les
cris de la mendiante ses cris de joie
oui elle crie elle rit criante et les
criantes comme on parlait vous dire mais
parlant elle est criante
les cris de la femme dans l'homme assis
dans le couloir des cris de votre mère
écrit énormément ces différends créé
écouter mais vous écris les yeux que ce
sont des crises j'ai pas dit ça lui même
bien entendu on crie beaucoup ma mère
crie tout le temps oui comme moïse dans
les déserts il était tellement imprégnés
de l'idée de dieu qui ne pouvait plus
parler crier ma mère était tellement
imprégnés de la justice dont elle avait
été victime qu'elle criait ces choses-là
au vide
vous criez vous devez ça m'arrive je
prie très bien dans les tournages quand
il faut faire le silence on me demande
de crier enfin je crie pas pour faire
non je crie pas méchamment
et puis une expression on retrouve qui
est déjà dans la mort semble-t-il c'est
exténué de désirs des personnages
exténué de désir s'est uni et qui à mon
avis d'ailleurs disent bien aux
personnages ils sont exténués de désir
j'ai dit à propos de l'aisne lagonelle
we are we ll lagonelle certains
personnages il ya quatre pages sur elle
dans un clip c'est une
à votre âge à peu près étale à
n'empêcherait vous parler par exemple
dessin c'est hélène koné 6 et 10 comme
si vous aviez vu hier oui je vois le
corps très bien là encore sublime vous
voyez aussi je vois bien il dit
l'oubliable vous verrez les cinq qu'elle
portait le corps portait comme vous
offrir la main oui j'étais c'était un
amoureux un désir qui ne s'est jamais
déclarée et qui était exténué envie
complètement exténué et mikit et annexes
qui était un désir comme on dirait une
sorte d' épiphénomène de désir centrale
qui allaitent aux chinois vous voyez le
corps de la main oui très bien
visage beaucoup moins je décris le cas
c'est un peu le corps du petit frère
aussi on a mieux son cas comme encore ah
oui parce que vous voyez plus que vous
voyez bien oui
donc la romancière du désir ou
l'écrivain du désir plus tôt ce sera la
plus générale c'est une formule qui vous
résume bien ça y est on cherche souvent
des femmes le journaliste un bon cherche
à faire à titre d'un journal c'est bien
sûr ça ne désigne pas il faut il faut
qu'il vaut mieux ne pas écrire à de la
corse ou via du regard et vous revoir
vos commandes ben moi je dis pas non
oui mais ça c'est le journaliste et le
travail de journaliste c'est bien car
c'est un écrivain ou quoi je sais pas
vous prendre au dépourvu
enfin on pourrait trouver de
l'existentialisme non validé il veut pas
bon là je vais reprendre la main je vais
citer ceux ci qui page 57 et c'est une
phrase de votre mère et vous allez voir
pour ça va nous amener ceux ci elle elle
crée way écrit écrit qu'il ne faut rien
attendre
jamais ni d'une quelconque personne ni
d'un quelconque état ni d'un quelconque
dieu c'est aussi votre avis oui
les gens qui attendent de l'aide par
exemple pour écrire vous savez qui
attendent d'avoir du temps qu attendent
d'avoir du calme
une maison times c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai c'est le texte
si donc à écrire partout les clés
partout c'est pas des écrivains je veux
dire ça c'est pas qu'il serait pas un
seul nom si oui pour gaza si par exemple
un peu les gens croient rien et conflit
soit enfin pour moi si je me dis on
cherche plus à la grange est plutôt à la
campagne pour écrire la manche à la mer
et tout ça je n'avais pas de lieu pour
écrire je transportais mon manuscrit de
lieux en lieux
on ne le faisait pas cette histoire là
et vous c'est dans ce sens là que je
vous le dis je ne raconte pas d'histoire
là dessus et je ne me raconte pas
d'histoires je sais que quand on n'écrit
pas et bien on écrit par mme alors vous
n'y aurez quand et si vous voulez c'est
sain c'est nonce a rejoint ça et vous
savez il ya des gens qui disent les gens
étaient choqués certaines scandalisé par
votre page 85
vous racontez vos mais pendant la guerre
vous avez connu
ramon fernandez qui était un
collaborateur et vous dit ceci
collaborateurs les fernandez et moi deux
ans après la guerre membre du parti
communiste français l'équivalent cet
absolu définitive c'est la même chose a
même pitié le même appel au secours la
même débilité du jugement la même
superstition 10 ans qui consiste à
croire à la solution politique du
problème personnel vous êtes consciente
que vous choquer beaucoup affirmant ceci
est mon avis je t'avais qu'à savoir
l'état de choses avaient eu lieu avec à
les connaître et procèdent 33 le pacte
germano soviétique la liquidation de la
pologne
vous avez eu lieu d'attraction de 36
ce avec à me renseigner mais c'est une
aventure personnelle oui bien sûr c'est
à dire que j'étais dirige était
complètement dans le désarroi
c'est ça la croyance dans l'est de la
solution est politique au malheur
personnel mon mari était déporté 14
camarades étaient déportés j'étais
complètement je sais pas s'ils étaient
vivants enfin c'est affreux et je me
suis dit je vais vu à de gaulle à avait
désarmer les milices patriotiques de
paris ça m'avait eu terriblement choqué
ça j'y vais retrouver la fraternité la
terre du parti écolo collaborateurs
c'est pareil la collaboration aux frais
comme ça des occasions comme la fin de
la guerre offrit l'occasion de
s'inscrire au parti il a monté de
violence si vous voulez la violence de
meurtres d'assassinats nazis offrait à
d'autres gens des espèces davanture
davanture nouvelle si vous voulez il
n'allait pas jusque là les gens que je
connais mais c'était un nouveau
voisinage il nouvelle rap une autre
point de vue
que les points de vue enfin c'était très
très très restreint le champ politique
français était très restreint ce moment
là c'est une occasion de changer de
direction de sa vie comme une invite à
venir à venir se perdre
il ya une perdition là dedans parce que
duras collaborateurs les niçois sur sur
notre sol
et qu'est ce que c'est exactement la
terre existe et collaborateurs il y des
collaborateurs et puis voilà c'était par
hasard et il n'aurait jamais fait de mal
à une mouche ces gens là jamais moi j'ai
vu des femmes tondues parce que vous
avez aimé des allemands du autant
horrifié que parler ce qui s'est passé
au temps mais on devenait aussi c'est
pourquoi programme blanchir mois et
puisse élire bazillac par exemple si la
firme asia qu il avait calé à choisir
j'étais très jeune je sais pas l'âge qui
l'avait jeu
enfin on devenait on était communiste
ont été stalinien aussi par utopie c'est
aussi parce qu'on croit en croire au
bonheur du lendemain etc
il a marseille c'est comme si vous me
disiez maintenant je connais rien de
l'afghanistan je connais pas la réaction
de marché et de justin qui ont rigolé à
la télévision en parlant dans la joie en
parlant de la délivrance de l'avocate
east hants par les soviétiques
si vous me disiez tout d'un coup j'ai
peur je savais pas ce jour là j'ai je
vais pas regarder la télé j'ai rien à
dire le sivos savez ces choses là mais
je croyais pour le plupart des gens
c'étaient les choses inévitable les
exactions d d d d aix est inévitable
et qu'est ce qu'ils savaient comme nous
vous ne savez pas les camps sait très
peu de choses des sur les camps on
savait l'existence de doha c'est tout le
tout jeune femme du programme tue plus
rien chez mitterrandienne à g pour la
personne de mitterrand femme de gauche
nom ne vous dit non non je peux rien
voilà mes mitterrandienne pourquoi parce
que mitterrand et à beaune écrivain est
si non pourquoi
parce que c'est une personne à part
entière il a rien derrière
il n'a pas l'argent et il n'a pas
d'idéologie
en tout cas ils la contourne tellement
idéologique
c'est sur ce grand art ce soir du
seigneur de la personne de sa personne
les senioriales jetons il fait des
choses très très bien les choses
définitives sur lesquels on ne reviendra
plus jamais sur la peine de mort par
exemple il a fait un miracle actualiser
la crise économique
j'aime pas beaucoup saigné la logistique
ou voyez ce que je veux dire tout le
monde réfléchit là dessus maintenant on
pense à la crise
on a subi plus seulement on y pense et
ça c'est mitterrand je remarque aussi
que ont tout jamais votre nom au bas des
pétitions des intellectuels non quand
même bon non je fais des choses de
signer pour jouer amnistie
internationale
ah oui quand même
depuis longtemps
j'ai signé peau des dents des étrangers
surtout enfin vous me croyez plus aux
lendemains qui chantent au bonheur
universel
[Musique]
rien que ce ferry s'affairaient mais
c'est fini c'est fini les parties
communes vous en parler parce que sa
mise en définitive 10% c'est la fin tout
à fait là il ya quelque chose qui dure
c'est lesquelles me française ça dure
depuis quelques siècles
vous savez qui a déjà une marguerite qui
est très célèbre académie française
c'était la première qui est rentré
est-ce que vous marie thurso nerfs donc
est ce que marie duras par exemple si un
fort parti l'académicien se déclaraient
tourelles
qu'est-ce que comment elle accueillerait
cette roquette je suis prête à tout je
crains pas la polémique
oui en quoi je suis prête à tout pour
moi je vais pas prêt mais si regardez je
suis là ont beaucoup de m
je suis là un peu gêné alors donc c'est
à six mois j'avais juré que jamais je
viendrai à wimille fois rigolo mais je
vous ai vu l'a souvent vu quand même
très complètement charmant c'est vrai
que quelqu'un de dire comme ça je pense
mais c'est très gentil mais ce qui est
des académiciens qui sont très charmant
ils vont ils vont vous circonvenir oui
mais j'ai un passé un passé trop où le
vrai qu'un livre comme ça pour entrer à
l'académie
colin sens et la honda famille londres
et société non je trouve cette chose de
trop risqué pendant l'académie pour
risquer
alcool aussi j'ai dû m'acquitter pas
déclaré a déclaré simplement ils sont
plus discrets que vous et tous n'ont pas
terminé cette émission sont les
dernières minutes devrait revenir à
marguerite duras avant la main quand
vous étiez dans la concession comment
étiez-vous quelle petite fille était
vous parce que là vous vivez dans une
nature conduite mon style et des des
canons et les serpents des félins etc
vous avez peu ben oui on était là dedans
avec le petit frère
oui on avait tout le temps peur mais
peut-être que c'était ça le jeu majeur
voiliers ont sauvé toutes les siestes g
on allait dans la montagne à social
toujours le sien et on entendait le
tigre quelquefois on allait aux
embouchures de duras ont tué des
crocodiles enfin lui les panthères
noires
ça fait une enfance différente de la
vôtre et vous étiez complètement
insouciante
ils m'ont fait traîner au bout du monde
je vais partout je suivais jeux partout
partout dans la forêt jusqu'au village
haut de la montagne
je n'ai aucune faute au tir endroit là
et après avoir connu tous à vous je
suppose qu on a eu plus peur du tout un
programme de vie j'ai eu peur des
allemands
j'ai peur de la police allemande mais
autrement dont rien ne me fait peur en
france si peut-être quand même certains
partis politiques
j'avais la peur qu'on a eu pendant trois
ans à paris d'être arrêté par la police
j'ai beau en parler à des gens qui ont
peur de la police ici mais je pense que
ce n'est pas communicables et puis alors
quand vous arrivez en france avec l âge
quand vous êtes un musulman
eh bien je viens pour oui je viens 17
ans et 18 ans et comment vous vous
installer facilement vous vous adaptez
facilement mais j'étais d'abord chez mon
frère puisque ma mère m'avait obligé non
mais comment vous êtes un pays quand
même tout nouveau pour vous là je peux
mourir d'ennui d'elle à 18 ans cet
étrange s'ennuyer de sa mère à ce point
j'appelais suffisamment après les deux
ans passés puisque je restais deux ans
isabelle marie presque le chinois la
mode est vraiment vous avez vous
fouillez j'ai vraiment vécu comme tout
le monde et est ce que l'amant en ce
moment il a été le premier il reste
quand même le plus singulier le plus
étonnant le plus mais reste
l'éblouissement
des maisons voici les dernières lignes
superbes du livre et la chine le plus
beau des années après la guerre après
les mariages les enfants les divorces
les livres il était venu à paris avec sa
femme
c'est donc la main il lui avait
téléphoné c'est moi elle l'avait reconnu
de la voix il avait dit je voulais
seulement entendre votre voix
elle avait dit c'est moi bonjour il
était intimidé il avait peur comme avant
sa voix tremblait tout à coup avec le
tremblement tout à coup elle avait
retrouvé l'accent de la chine
il savait qu'elle avait commencé à
écrire des livres il l'avait su par la
mère qui l'avait revu à saigon et puis
il lui avait dit lui avait dit que
c'était comme avant qu'ils les mettent
encore qu'ils ne pourraient jamais cessé
de l'aimer qu'ils l'aimeraient jusqu'à
sa mort est-ce que vous sur votre
rigueur vous aurez une pensée pour la
main le premier possible
merci marie duras alors des ouvrages
pour montrer alors voilà il a beaucoup
en livre de poche alors on peut trouver
ça sont des classiques ça c'est les
éditions de minuit dans la collection
double qui ont publié moderato cantabile
les petits chevaux de tarquinia
hiroshima mon amour donc là c'est le
scénario les dialogues du film de
resnais le marin de gibraltar et le
ravissement de lol v stein et bien
entendu on vous a vu vous montrez
barrage contre le passé nos barrages
comme le pass le pacifique alors d'autre
part je vous signale alors ça ce sont
des ddd trois citations des pièces
détruire dit-elle sas aux éditions de
minuit
savannah bay je vais le dire à la fin ça
agatha aussi qu'on va créer ou reprendre
alors ça ce sont des chroniques publiée
dans libération en l'été 80 toujours
publie aux éditions de minuit les lieux
de marguerite duras à ceux sur le texte
d'une émission de télévision qu'on a
faite chez vous avec eux donc des et
toutes les photos qu'on a pu voir durant
cette émission on les a puisé dans ce
petit livre lim qui a été fait avec
michel porte l'homme assis dans le
couloir auquel j'ai fait allusion alors
ça ce sont trois textes votés publié
très récemment et qui sont des textes
très très court qui sont une force
faille en tout cas pour deux d'entre eux
une forte charge érotique notamment
l'homme assis dans le couloir et la
maladie de la mort et puis l'homme
atlantique
ça alors là je me tourne vers le cinéma
le camion de marguerite duras position
de minuit deux livres qui sont publiées
au mercure de france qui sont réédités
fort à-propos l'éden cinéma
et puis là le navire hms nike césar et
les mains négatives orolia steiner et
trois fois au mercure de france
je signale aussi et toujours le cinéma
maric duras alors pas un seul ensemble
de textes de vous
de là quand il ya un texte qui est
souvent cité de jacques lacan qui
apprécie beaucoup votre maurice blanchot
mascolo vous aviez gauthier viviane
forrester aux éditions albatros de
nicolis berne à marguerite duras tourner
un film ça c'est india sont bien je
crois c'est le tournage de digne à son
tour aux éditions albatros avec donc
votre témoignage avoué puis des acteurs
des films séries michael lonsdale
toujours le cinéma ça c'est des cahiers
un numéro spécial des cahiers du cinéma
qui est paru en juin 80 qu'il ya
d'ailleurs des textes qui sont souvent
assez drôle de dire et donc et danse
était que vous expliquez votre
conception du cinéma
là on n'a pas eu le temps d'en parler
mais ce n'était pas le sujet bien
entendu mari de duras les yeux verts
notamment votre rencontre avec godard
qui est fort drôle de marguerite duras
marie duras à montréal publié les textes
réunis et présentés par suzanne l'ami
henri roy aux éditions spirale ça c'est
votre séjour au québec sur les textes
des conférences vous avez donné des
interviews que vous avez accordé enfin
voila c'est donc tout ça je le signale
aussi un sage les reçus cette semaine ça
vient de paraître vraiment c'est
opportun aux éditions l'âge d'homme
marie dura ce médium du réel de
madeleine à la salle r j'en ai lu
quelques pages s'avère très intelligent
très intelligent très original et puis
j'ai pas fini ça c'est les éditions des
femmes qui ont publié deux deux
cassettes à leurs maris et duras lui par
catherine deneuve ce je crois que c'est
les petits chevaux de tarquinia ça et
puis married duras qui se lit elle même
et ça sont des textes de l'été 80 je
crois bien
voilà donc son 2 2 et puis alors voilà
le monument ça le monument ça vient de
sortir
c'est l'édition vidéographie critique de
marie duras autrement dit là dedans il y
a voilà je peux pas les ouvrir dans ça
tout va tomber il y a cinq cas cette
vidéo qui représentent 15 heures du
cinéma de marie duras enfin il ya une
chaque film est suivi d'un entretien
avec eux je sais ce qui est ce qui vous
a interviewé dominique noguez gc ca
bruno nuytten
alors là dedans on retrouve donc
nathalie granger air india song le
camion césar et son nom de venise dans
calcutta dr et c est tout ça est publié
c'est l'oeuvre du bureau d'animation
culturelle du ministère des relations
extérieures
c'est sa deuxième usine c ur au bilan
oui puis j'en fais jean jean rouch
ah oui ils ont fait un boulot mais ça je
l'ignorais très bien alors ça et on m'a
signalé que
j'ai ce que je dis enfin c'est en
souscription jusqu'à la fin de l'année
et puis après ce sera en vente dans
l'est dans les magasins de deux vidéos
ce site magnifique
c'était magnifique mais c'est très très
bien leur boulot et très très bon compte
alors là vraiment je fais un travail de
premier rang de ces familles je le dis
puisque si c'est des gens que je connais
oui il ya des lieux oui je signale
qu'avec sa filiale un texte de où il ya
tous les entretiens que vous avez eu à
propos de tous ses films et
interviennent aussi delphine seyrig
michael lonsdale et beaucoup d'autres
stars du bâtard du exactement dit si on
vidéographique critique voilà c'est
complet je signale parce que vraiment
vous êtes vraiment dans l'actualité un
assez fou je m'en plains pas alors
savannah bay savanna b est repris au
théâtre du rond point par la compagnie
renaud barrault et c'est d'ailleurs
madeleine renaud bien entendu qui joue
le principal rôle oseo lucernaire
théâtre noir hiroshima mon amour dans
une mise en scène de michael lonsdale
mais ça alors à partir du 2 octobre au
château de beauregard par la comédie de
caen agata dans une mise en scène de
gérard agathe âge les montrer c'est une
création j'ai l'impression agatha ou
bien je sais donner à paris ceux déjà
donné à paris très bien et puis je
signale qu'en janvier prochain le
théâtre de la criée à marseille
présentera la mouette de tchekhov dans
une traduction nouvelle de marie dura
une adaptation une adaptation bien et
puis alors on
pour changer le générique et bien j'ai
vient de puiser là la musique du
générique d'un set dans ce disque ce 33
tours qui vient de sortir aux chants du
monde ce sont les musiques de films de
carlos d'alessio qui est un très
remarquable compositeur et j'ai bien
entendu choisi la très belle musique au
piano digne dias ongles alors voilà je
vous demande de l'écouté merci en tout
cas et merci pour cette soixante dix
minutes passées
[Musique]